we have this from the post millennial
twitter employees go absolutely insane
after elon musk buys the company quote i
feel like i'm going to throw up i really
don't want to work for a company that's
owned by elon musk well welcome to the
real world bringing in the book the
craziest part take a look at this from
bloomberg twitter locks down product
changes after agreeing to muskbed the
fear is that rogue employees will nuke
the platform so they had to lock
everything down
that's how crazy things have gotten now
there's there's one funny tweet that i
want to highlight
sean davis from he's at the federalist
right
ceo and co-founder of the federalist he
tweets uh uh this from talman smith who
says quote
a part of what i do i'm sorry talman
smith is quoting somebody else i don't
want it's not a tribute to him quote a
part of what i do is monitoring toxicity
and health in the trends i don't know if
this will impact my job directly i want
to still have a job and i don't know how
this impacts that
they added they're pretty broken wish i
had a nuanced take on it but i'm just
scared and sad well i will tell you how
this buyout will affect your job uh it
won't because you won't have one ha ha
no i i think elon musk will keep a lot
the same
i think the first thing's going to
happen is he'll have to go in and learn
how the machine works then he'll
probably throw up into a couple paper
bags realizing what's going on behind
the scenes both because people post
horrifying things and both because the
censorship and manipulation is worse
than anyone realized and then he'll try
to get a handle on it yeah i mean this
is part of what's so golden about this
entire thing you have all these twitter
employees absolutely losing their minds
just behaving like unhinged maniacs as
if we're supposed to see that go oh man
i'm sorry that they don't have free
reign anymore yeah i don't really want
scared and sad people running my twitter
accounts exactly just so you know scared
and sad guy
this was exactly the reaction everybody
predicted right i mean they're like yeah
we finally got rid of donald trump
because he's such a poopy head i
couldn't stand him like why is that your
decision
shouldn't be i don't think any one
person should have the reins on that
kind of power right now
well and again they have played their
hand they're showing that these are not
cool calm and collected people who can
make reasonable decisions in a time of
crisis look at the way they're acting
right now elon someone they don't like
now has control of their company they're
all they're in history honestly now i'm
just doing some math i'm looking as of
december 21 there's
more than 7 500 twitter employees that's
a lot of people and elon is is pretty i
would call them cutthroat what would you
say you do here yeah exactly they were
at home that was a big part of this
twitter thread too that tim had pulled
up earlier as they were saying most of
twitter employees work from home now
they're wondering if that's going to
change
i think that he's going to slash the
employees this is what i said what would
happen if elon musk just shut down the
vpn locked out all the employees except
for the knocks at the data center would
twitter become a better website just
from that
what would that look like exactly you
wouldn't have these toxicity moderators
for one i mean i don't know
yeah toxicity
firing
you know you know elon musk is in for a
rude awakening i gotta be i gotta be
honest i think he's a smart guy i think
he's he's planned strategically i think
he cornered twitter the shareholders may
still try and push back but i really
don't see what their what their votes
are going to be i mean you're getting
free money
but
let me i think ian understands this
especially having worked with minds
when eon said when uh when when eon when
eli it's getting to that i fused them
both
when elon says he wants free speech
i don't think he understands
truly what that will mean to open the
floodgates and i think even elon musk
must have a line so i'll po i'll pose
this
it is free speech
to show images of dead babies
because you want people to know about
the horrors of what's going on with
abortion say right james yeah and so how
will people know they don't want it
unless they can see what's actually
happening
will advertisers want to be on a
platform where there are photos of dead
babies it's an interesting question to
be fair i think what eon muskling i saw
a thong for like
yeah no
it's an interesting question i think
this is uh a really complicated problem
that not a lot of people consider which
is that
even with these conservative
alternatives that they're trying to
launch if any of them ever happen to
catch on or even with this what musk is
trying to do implementing a more neutral
model with respect to speech
at some point you're right it could
affect profitability and then what
happens then
yeah i think that the ad revenue model
is dying it's it's useless well it's
getting to the point where it's useless
that's why elon says he wants to drive
up memberships so
well i just want to i like what
eon muskland no i like what elon musk is
saying uh about a lot of this but here's
what i'm curious about without looking
at this through any ideological
framework tim you were sort of
mentioning earlier that restricting
certain advertisers from being able to
pay twitter to have their ads placed
there could be failing to fulfill their
fiduciary responsibility do you think
there's an argument to be made that the
shareholders allowing unfettered free
speech could also be failing to uphold
their fiduciary responsibility because
it could make the company less
profitable
i would argue
i i will actually address that i said
when it come when it comes to politics
the board might actually argue that
taking on advertisers would hurt us
which is why they justify it but climate
change there's no there's no
justification for that no no i agree
with you i guess my point is
no no my point is do you think that's
going to pose a threat to elon being
able to make this a free speech platform
are they going to say we are failing to
fulfill ourselves we don't have a
shareholder he's taking it oh oh that's
right he's taking a private i believe
all right yeah yeah beautiful you're
right yeah which means he could go on
and he can read your dms he elon can
scream to anyone
you know you gotta understand what he's
buying right now he's buying the ability
to dm
britney spears he's gonna find the
ability to read his ex's messages well
like somebody somebody who who's who's
this madonna someone who who's who's his
age eminem elon musk now has the power
to open up dms to anyone he wants he
owns it it's his well let me ask you a
question would you rather own the
washington post or twitter not even a
question you know the answer to that one
man so so who's ahead in the billionaire
game jeff bezos or elon musk oh bezos
says and we know this because he's
trying to throw shade at musk on twitter
well you mean
but bezos bought washington post for
like 200 million
right yeah elon put up 44 billion um it
was funny
elon's or i'm sorry uh bezos said
something along the lines of does china
now have a stake in the public square in
response to elon musk purchasing
i want to go back to that to the free
speech point i was making before elon
musk has a line
and his and aws which twitter is on
right it's on aws yeah well actually i
don't know if twitter is twitter is
twitters they might have their own
infrastructure i suppose i think they
have their own info i would not trust
aws well yeah but twitter would i mean
they're bored 2020 twitter chooses aws
there you go exactly
so what happens when elon musk says i
want unfettered free speech which
results in let's just be real well
you're going to get a lot of people who
are even on the left who are going to
masquerade as the right saying racial
slurs so that elon musk's so the the the
the chain link in the infrastructure of
twitter
revolts against him so you're gonna have
aws saying we won't host this because
there's people posting untoward content
you're gonna have the app store is
saying until you clean this up elon musk
can take twitter
but everything around him can you know
the entirety of silicon valley can
surround him and shut him down so how
how much could elon musk tolerate how
much can twitter tolerate and then
how much can they withstand a barrage
from silicon valley he may be the world
the world's richest man but the combined
wealth and power of the entirety of
silicon valley and venture capital
surrounding it i don't think he he can
be he can beat that no well that's what
i'm saying like expanding free speech
and then banning people is probably
going to be very late in the game right
now he just wants to develop a
consistent set of policies that are
transparent and that
for them to have a problem with that
would be revealing more about themselves
and about elon and i'll give you another
idea does elon taking over twitter
embolden a mark zuckerberg
to allow facebook to become a bit more
free and transparent because he's
getting the same pressures that elon
musk is and it's killing facebook what
did their stock drop like one third in
one night they can use this as an excuse
and say in order for us to compete now
we've got a private company worth 50
billion dollars
and it's one of the biggest social pla
social media platforms in the world
their allowing of free speech is making
people want to leave our platform sorry
shareholders it is our fiduciary duty we
must start unbanning i don't know if
they'll do it because i think they're
they're ideologically driven not profit
driven but that's a possibility but i
think that's a difference we have i
don't think it's an issue of
shareholders it's you know an issue of
political pressure i mean we were
talking about how like this you know
california politicians were telling
facebook and twitter ban these guys
censor those guys barack obama is coming
on saying that there's too much trash on
the internet it needs to be banned you
have political figures in this country
who are openly advocating against the
first amendment and using their
political muscle to make these private
companies do their bidding something
about free speech when we talk about
free speech we got to define it firstly
it's the american the united states of
america's version of it is enshrined in
the constitution that kind of free
speech where you can't say certain
things in that kind of free speech so
that isn't translating the internet it
doesn't translate to the internet you
can't it's they're all authoritarian
networks that are owned by someone that
can ban anything at any time yeah
there's no free speech yeah so saying
bring free speech to twitter doesn't
it's it's a non-sequitur it doesn't make
sense even even gab doesn't have
absolute free speech no and nor should
spam is a new a new phenomenon and and
dachshund because we all agreed okay
doxing crosses the line
even andrew torba of gab said that like
you said showing pictures of like
gruesome stuff that's free speech but
you don't you know there's no times in
places
well that's up to the authoritarian
owner of the company whether i should be
allowed i understand that but so
so i would say
people typically say free speech is the
expression of political thoughts ideas
etc and so we try to understand in that
in that framework spam doesn't fit that
if someone is trying to shut down the
conversation by screaming
some would argue that's not free speech
that's just screaming in fact that's
shutting people down there's there's
also there's also property rights so if
someone comes into your business and
they start telling you something you
don't want to hear you can kick them out
of the building and the government can't
say no you have to let them sit there
free speech to bake their cake for that
that's not true ian if i come into your
establishment you can kick me out for
any reason not if you say if you come
into the restaurant and start talking
about your your protected
your protected status
you you can ask me to leave your
premises at any moment for any reason
that's property rights that's part of
your property that's not that's not true
i mean
give me an example
the 1964 civil rights act protects
special classes uh in public
accommodation meaning i'm talking about
private accommodation this is all
private twitter's a private company
right you don't need well let me know
hold on you misunderstand public
accommodation means like a mcdonald's
it's privately owned but it's open to
the public if i walk in and say and
scream something like my dog you know
bites strangers and they say please sir
be quiet and you won't they can kick you
out
if you go in and start screaming
something about a protected class now
they're in in a troubled situation if
they kick you out they could argue he
was screaming of course the individual
say i went in there and started saying i
am this protected class so they kicked
me out that's where it gets okay if
you're saying mcdonald's is a public
accommodation then i'm open to that
argument i just have mcdonald's is a
public accommodation yeah public
accommodations are like services and
buildings that are open to the public so
like tim cass is a business it's private
property it is not a public
accommodation people can't come here
wendy's is because they want you to come
into their building but that means they
have to under the the i believe the 1964
civil rights act they cannot deny
so they they can put up signs all day
and night saying we reserve the right to
refuse service to anybody
you get into muddy territory because of
course you can kick someone out for
screaming but if they're screaming
things about a protected class their
argument in court will now go up against
yours are you saying that if like a
homeless person goes into a wendy's and
just goes to sleep in one of the booths
that they can't kick the person no you
can kick the person out but like if you
kick a person out just because they're a
protected class and they can prove that
in court
then they got a case against you kick
them out for loitering yes right so ian
if a black person walked into a wendy's
the manager can't say you're loitering
get out technically they can but we all
see what happens they lose in court but
my point is that the media goes goes off
and says they're racist yeah there might
be a cultural backlash but technically
they can't no no ian it is not all right
that's not true
arguing about this anymore my point is
twitter can ban anyone at any time for
any reason they don't need a reason
that's mostly because of section 230.
they actually have a special provision
that allows them to bypass the public
accommodation provision of the of the
1964 civil rights act this was always
the craziest thing to me that
you can't deny someone access to public
to a public accommodation on the basis
of certain specialized uh classes or you
know identities or whatever
but twitter gets to because of section
230 meaning quite literally someone can
post that they believe in gay marriage
and twitter can say no you don't ban and
i'm like but wait a minute
it's because
i forgot i forgot it was explained to me
by a lawyer it may have been will
chamberlain i'm not sure but someone
explained that uh the expression of
opinion is not
you know the same thing as denying
someone's service because of who they
are
so like if you say i will not provide
you service you have to leave because of
this thing about you and i just said
that's ridiculous because they could
just argue that's why they got banned
and
basically the broad protections of
section 230 make it impossible to win on
that front now if you want to talk about
is this company a public accommodation i
don't know i feel like it's very fascist
to for a government to tell a private
company what they have to do with their
company you could argue that there's
monopolies and that's the government's
jobs to break up monopolies well that's
the big issue right and they say like
well what this person said is very
offensive but then like i said in the
past two years you've had people make
very reason very cogent arguments that
are not at all offensive but because
they go against like the financial
interests of blackrock you know they get
banned i mean that is a much
there is no philosophical case against
that right it's purely a political case
there
um well i don't know if you know i mean
with the with the lockdowns i mean you
saw it more than anything people didn't
want ma children getting masked people
were getting tired of the lockdowns the
lockdowns weren't doing anything but
they were getting banned for saying it
you know i mean just look at the trucker
convoy in canada
so so my my point earlier on though
because i think people at least some
people misunderstand
free speech on twitter means people will
be saying we'll be responding to every
post with a racial slur it means there
will be people who will do that
you have the option to block them that's
reality if you want to go out to the
town square you're going to hear people
screaming nasty things that they're
going to be holding up really awful
signs
and that's reality you can't hide from
it twitter seems to think that they
wanted to craft this utopian world where
they would decide what things were toxic
and what things weren't
we'll see if elon musk will tolerate
that
because
either he says free speech or he decides
from his own personal morals some things
are okay and some things aren't
i'm looking up this uh federal
accommodations public combinations
things you can't discriminate on basis
of race color religion or national
origin or disabilities
right but i but a private company could
still toss you out if they just don't
like the way you smell right yes okay so
the the issues to me everything the
issue arises when you have a person who
is a protected class and they don't like
the way they smell then they're gonna be
like oh it was my race and you'd be like
no it's because you were stinking up the
establishment and then they'll say we'll
see you in court and you'll lose and
guess what you will maybe that's it
that's an issue in where in l.a where
some tweaker will come into
establishment and start harassing people
and even getting into fights and at that
point you got to freaking wrestle them
out
establishment i feel like all this
argument about free speech on the
internet is a facade a fallacy there is
none you cannot have free speech in a
private company good luck trying to you
got to fix the way that that is built
i've told you how to do it in the past
you free the software code you get it
off your back let other people spin up
their own twitters with their own terms
of service so you can pick the one that
works you're contradicting yourself and
they all interoperate i don't think so
you are if you said there can't be free
speech on the internet well there can be
you just explain how to do it
you can give different networks the
ability to choose to have free speech on
them if they want but you can't make
someone give you free speech i think
this
what do you mean like if you walk into a
place where you're not wanted and you
say what you think is your right to say
they can they can stop you not everyone
can cancel you off on the internet they
can so uh we talked about this with uh
occupy wall street it's what's called a
privately owned public space yeah and
the courts ruled that even though it's
privately owned because it's a park open
to the public this is zuccotti they had
to allow protest
so i argued twitter should be the same
way a privately owned public space sure
you can privately own it you can put up
whatever billboards you want but if it
is a speech
business open to the public you should
not be able to bar people for protests
yeah ian i get what you're saying it's a
complicated question but there was
actually a supreme court decision marsh
versus alabama in the 1940s and they
basically determined that in a company
town they were not able to prohibit a
woman from passing out religious
literature because it was protected by
the first amendment even though it was
their private property
i think it has something to do with
taking up a certain amount of the public
square that you are now required to
uphold the law of the land oh that's
okay and the united states is the first
so she came into my house and started
passing out religious stuff i can't say
you can't do that but i can say get out
of my house yeah so well my
understanding and again i'm not a legal
expert i'm not an expert on this case by
any means i've heard a bit about it but
my understanding is basically that if
you own a large enough or you occupy a
large enough percentage of the public
square as a private business there are
certain first amendment responsibilities
that you have there's a back and forth
on this actually in the state of
california where malls are technically
supposed to allow people to leaflet and
do political activity but then they sort
of go back and say no we have the right
to regulate in the interest of keeping
the mood of our mall
so like for example you go to some malls
or like okay you can go set up a table
over there but you have to like you know
file an application and give a deposit
and all that we ignore those when i when
i was doing fundraising they would tell
you and this happened all the time go to
a shopping center you're allowed to
work for causes and fundraise and and
protest they will tell you you can't
they will tell you they're calling the
police they can't do anything and if the
police show up the police will defend
you and sure enough every time the
police came up apologized to me and just
said ignore him you're allowed to if
like you're outside you're on a you're
in a parking lot outside waving to
people as long as you're not being
you're not obstructing anybody as long
as you're not screaming anybody you're
just waving and handing out flyers and
asking people to talk totally fine
protect it under the first amendment i
think part of why i'm concerned with
what you were saying about
treating twitter as part of the commons
and just letting it fly is how will you
moderate that
who's in charge then of moderating it
like if it's a private company you're
like you can't moderate it the way you
want
now figure out how to moderate it that
doesn't
okay we have police problem solved right
well we have laws and things of the
constitution that guides the actions if
someone if someone posts something
illegal which there are many things
illegal under the law then
there you go the police get called
intervene arrest the person and then if
it's if if elon's twitter decides we're
going to immediately remove any any
anything mate anything made uh we're
made aware of that's illegal will be
removed instantly the police will be
informed but then trespassing is illegal
so if you're on twitter
if you're in their space that's it's
just a different environment i just i
just want to read
i just want to read one sentence from
this decision that i pulled up here uh
justice hugo l black noted that and
quote here the more an owner for his
advantage opens up his property for use
by the public in general the more do his
rights become circumscribed by the
statutory and constitutional rights of
those who use it
so
i i having making a private company
act
as if it's the united states government
is challenging
i agree that these things are in the
comments i do believe they are in the
comments far far right ian crossland
free market i don't think that forcing
twitter to change its its terms makes
any sense it's super dangerous precedent
if the government starts deciding what
companies have to how they have to
behave we're f but we're not right now
it's just a private a guy has bought it
and he's going to change it the way he
sees fit
yeah okay maybe let's let's let's let's
go to the store right here we got this
from timcast.com donald trump says he
will not return to twitter after elon
musk purchased the platform he'll make
improvements to it but i am going to be
staying on truth said trump oh boy i
don't think trump is actually on truth
he's not posting anything has he no i
don't know i'm not on it and i don't
think anyone else is either
i mean i i have an account there i don't
use yeah whatever i don't know quote
trump told fox news
i am not going on twitter i am going to
stay on truth i hope elon buys twitter
because he'll make improvements to it
and he's a good man but i'm going to be
staying on truth we're making million
we're taking in millions of people and
what we're finding is that the response
on truth is much better than being on
twitter that's just fundamentally not
true
and anyone of influence knows it all of
these conservatives are pointing out
that the left won't leave the platform
twitter is the place you got to be
because of platform monopoly
are you saying that the liar lied
i'm sorry
i'm saying he's wrong yeah what i was
gonna say here is that i think um you
know it's very noble and i would argue
in many ways a good thing when
conservatives try to start their own
platforms in this sphere but the problem
is twitter's utility is the fact that
basically everybody's on it and your
perspective can be heard by people who
didn't just come to hear a right-wing
perspective so you actually have the
possibility of changing people's minds
about things and so if elon musk is able
to make twitter or i should say eon um
muslin is able to make mush is able to
make twitter a more fair and open
platform for different political views
that would be much better for us as a
movement than to all
you know segregate ourselves to this
conservative website that other people
aren't seeing thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there